German Chancellor Angela Merkel is now
hinting in a recent series of comments
that she made that the United States is
increasingly just not an ally of Europe
but instead more of an adversary like
China and Russia which has to be dealt
with by Europe as an adversary rather
than as an ally and I know I know the
trumpets and the nationalists and the
isolationists and the reactionaries will
say David Europe who cares what Europe
thinks were the best will go it alone we
don't need anybody but this is actually
serious this is part of a geopolitical
realignment that is not good for the
United States it's happening as a result
of President Donald Trump and I'm gonna
explain why this is such a concern okay
so first of all on Gullah Merkel I'm -
Angela Merkel's left much to her left
but she's a skilled politician she's a
powerful leader she's respected by many
of our historical allies around the
world and when Donald Trump was elected
we actually did a segment asking who
will become the leader of the free world
with the United States laughably under
Donald Trump it was November 14th when
we did that story and my argument at the
time was that it would be on Gullah
Merkel the leader of the free world is
of course not a literal term it's a term
that is a colloquial term it dates back
to the Cold War and usually it applies
to the President of the United States or
the u.s. itself is sort of the Paramount
Democratic superpower and Donald Trump
as an embarrassment and as a destroyer
of geopolitical alliances is no longer
that leader and that leader
realistically is now on gala Merkel now
last week I told you that the superpower
triad of Russia China and the United
States is shifting in a way that is not
good for the United States if you're an
economic nationalist if you're a
geopolitical nationalist and you want
what's good for the United States
you see deteriorating us-china relations
with this constantly escalating trade
war while at the same time you see a
growing cooperation or Allegiance or
alliance rather between China and Russia
and that is a relationship that is
leaving the United States behind we
talked about that last week we now also
have Europe according to Merkel seeing
the United States more as part of those
adversaries like China and Russia rather
than as inherent and stable allies of
the European Union and of Germany and
this means that we're on the outs with
basically everybody at the same time and
that's not good for us let's look at
what Angela Merkel said quote there is
no doubt that Europe needs to reposition
itself in a changed world the old
certainties of the post-war order no
longer apply they meaning China Russia
and the US are forcing us time and again
to find common positions that is often
difficult given our different interests
but we do get this done think for
example of our policy regarding the
conflict in Ukraine our policies on
Africa to now follow a common strategy
which a few years ago would have been
unthinkable so we can't keep putting one
foot in front of the other
however our political power is not yet
commensurate with our economic strength
and the implication here is clear
European leaders more and more are not
seeing the Trump United States primarily
as an ally of Europe and why would they
and by the way remember when we had a
president when I as I as I watched
Angela Merkel give this speech and read
the transcript I was reminded of when we
also had a president who could speak in
a more sophisticated way not like a
fourth grader things have certainly
changed a lot every time I see other
world leaders speak I'm reminded of that
but in terms of the substance Merkel is
right to feel the way that she does
Trump ignorantly and irrationally
criticizes our historical European
allies Trump slams NATO Trump threatens
tariffs on the EU and European nations
and sets up another trade war similar to
the one with China that we can't win and
that is hugely destructive Trump backs
out of the Paris climate agreement and
is a complete non factor in the world
fight against climate change in which
Europe is a
player the United Kingdom is
increasingly at odds with the United
States and with Trump including over
Iran by the way which I'll talk about
next the world is increasingly getting
away
from the US dollar as a reserve currency
Trump is considering potentially
disastrous military action in multiple
places including Iran this is textbook
Russia geopolitics if you look at
Russian geopolitical strategy that
they've been crafting for 20-plus years
everything is going exactly the way they
want now I'm not saying I want to be
clear I'm not saying Putin is
orchestrating all of this I'm pointing
out that this is out of the literal
textbook foundations of geopolitics for
what Russia wants and benefits from
you've got an ignorant [ __ ] president
in the United States okay to put it very
simply you have the three major
superpowers US Russia China increasingly
positioned in a way that is not good for
the United States but very good for
Russia right the US and a massive trade
war with China to our detriment while
Russia slips in makes nice with China
and sort of puts us on the outs of that
very powerful geopolitical triangle and
meanwhile Trump slams NATO which is
exactly what Russia and Vladimir Putin
want and also self harms our alliances
with Europe which is exactly what Russia
and Vladimir Putin want so we end up
with nothing and with no one and it's I
mean Putin has hit the mango jackpot
here in Donald Trump for lack of a
better term and the United States is
both engaging in geopolitical and
economic policy that is damaging
internally and at the same time being
seen as the bad guy being seen as the
obstinate one that you can't really deal
with by more and more of the world this
is very very bad for the United States
and it is one of the many reasons why
this president needs to be removed from
power as quickly as possible at this
point I believe as I've been saying for
a while that the quickest path to that
is I don't even have to say it we all
know what it is and it's about 1617
months away at this point in time we've
got to do that
today's program is sponsored in part by
Blink accom / Pakman if you've not
already heard about blinky it's amazing
it's an app for your phone tablet or web
browser and what they do is they take
nonfiction books popular nonfiction
critically acclaimed nonfiction they
condense the book into a fifteen minute
audio book you get all the most
important information and insights from
each book but you can soak up the entire
essence of the book in one sitting I've
listened to a ton of books on blinkin
recent one is a Robert Rice's new book
the common good also bunk by Kevin Young
useful in preparing me for the
pseudo-science miniseries that we're
producing and if you are a david pakman
show viewer or listener you can get a 7
day free trial by going to blink is comm
slash Pakman if you're watching on
youtube use the link in the video
description
after the free trial if you like it you
can get the full access to thousands of
condensed audiobooks for about five
bucks a month that's be li NK is t.com
/p a que ma n